[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 la
crisis económica derivada de la pandemia
de kobe 19 ha hecho que las mujeres se
dediquen a la prostitución méxico es un
ejemplo de la crisis para sobrevivir en
medio de los bloqueos y sin apoyo de los
estados esta es una forma de llevar
sustento la ong brigada callejera de
apoyo a la mujeres dijo que la
prostitución aumentó 100 por ciento en
el país azteca vamos a analizar estas
cifras
en las calles de la ciudad de mexico se
ven las consecuencias de la pandemia
cada vez más mujeres se tienen que
recurrir a la prostitución como única
opción de ingresos su situación es cada
vez más precaria
algunas de ellas se habían retirado y
ahora se ven obligadas a volver nuestro
corresponsal mario carbón l tiene la
historia
claudia comenzó en el sexoservicio desde
muy jovencita un día conoció a un hombre
se enamoraron y la saco de trabajar pero
hoy la vida le ha dado un vuelco
a raíz de la pandemia y la pérdida de
trabajo en mi pareja yo tengo que
regresar al trabajo sexual ahora ella es
el sostén económico de su hogar pero una
década después de haberse retirado todo
es más complicado
ha sido muy difícil la situación volver
a regresar en primera por mi edad porque
hay muchas chicas ya mucho más jóvenes
que yo claudia no es la única en la
misma situación que ella hay muchas
otras mujeres
elvira madrid presidenta de la brigada
callejera de atención a la mujer ha
tenido que redoblar esfuerzos
antes de la pandemia detectamos en el
diagnóstico siete mil setecientos
compañeras ejerciendo el trabajo sexual
ya como en agosto que volvemos a hacer
este diagnóstico vimos que eran 15.200
porque porque la mayoría las habían
expulsado de sus trabajos
frida se ha dedicado al sexoservicio
durante 18 años y cuenta que nunca había
sido tan difícil como ahora la mayor
oferta más competencia
[Música]
no hay trabajo
te lo pongo así si yo trabajaba de las 8
a las 12 pues yo ya trabajaba y me iba a
mi casa ahora salgo a las 8 y de 8 a 6
de la mañana y eso a ver si trabajo en
el sistema de protección social
frida y claudia no figuran
si hay apoyos para madres solteras para
comerciantes para es para el otro pero
para la trabajadora sexual nomás no no
existimos no somos personas que nos ven
con nos discriminan por nuestro trabajo
de no ser por el apoyo médico y las
despensas que les ofrece la brigada
frida y sus colegas simplemente no
sobreviviría
para conversar del tema está en ellas
hoy desde ciudad de méxico liliana
vanegas ramírez ella es presidenta de la
fundación el camino a casa y activista
por los derechos humanos de las mujeres
liliana gracias por estar con nosotros y
vamos a empezar con las preguntas camino
a casa es un refugio para mujeres
víctimas de trata y de prostitución ante
el aumento de este mal llamado sexo o
servicio en mexico como están
concentrando ustedes sus esfuerzos para
ayudar a las mujeres
hola que tal buenos dias efectivamente
la fundación camino a casa es una
fundación que recibe a niñas y
adolescentes víctimas de la trata de
personas en su modalidad de explotación
sexual comercial infantil nosotros no
atendemos a personas que vienen del el
ejercicio de la prostitución de manera
voluntaria porque al ser menores de edad
se asume que ellas están bajo un esquema
de explotación
nosotros tenemos cifras de la uv en audi
sí que nos indican que el 90 por ciento
de las mujeres que están en estado de
prostitución la ejercen en un esquema de
esclavitud es decir en contra de su
voluntad y coaccionadas por personas que
se están beneficiando económicamente de
su servicio
y nuestro programa consiste en darles
atención integral para llevarlas a su
restauración ya que el ejercicio de la
prostitución
es una actividad que les afecta
profundamente en varias aspectos de su
vida y en su cerebro por por la cantidad
de violencia que esto tiene no este
ejercicio de esta actividad tiene mire
hay organizaciones y también hay
posturas que defienden que este sexo o
servicio o la prostitución debería
legalizarse como un trabajo formal sin
embargo las mujeres prostituídas son
mujeres que dan ejemplo de un obstáculo
grandísimo para que se alcance la
igualdad de género esta es una práctica
discriminatoria que atenta contra los
derechos de las mujeres y pues al final
dada la labor que usted hace desde su
institución le tengo que hacer la
pregunta inevitable la abolición es
realmente la única solución para acabar
con estos problemas que además se
exacerbaron con la pandemia
pues mira nosotros sin meterle aquí un
ánimo moralista ni un ánimo
discriminatorio
nos vamos sobre las cifras en los únicos
países en donde se ha logrado disminuir
la trata de personas ha sido en estos
países como la misma suecia que inicia
con el modelo abolicionista francia
bélgica quienes ofrecen opciones dignas
yo quiero comentarte que el ejercicio de
la prostitución
y viola por si mismo
priva a una persona de 12 derechos
humanos fundamentales entre ellos el
derecho a una vida libre de violencia
a la salud el acceso a la libertad el
acceso a derechos que son y la
inalienables y que son básicos y
fundamentales tú no puedes controlar lo
que una persona aunque ejerce la
prostitución por su propia voluntad
le puede suceder en un cuarto cerrado de
hotel con una persona con un cliente que
puede estar bajo el influjo de las
drogas del alcohol o puede tener traumas
o puede tener una obsesión que la haga
dejar todos sus derechos y que la
maltrate en una violencia extrema
entonces nosotros aquí cuestionamos el
término dignidad porque es esto una
profesión digna y yo se lo dejo a la
sociedad que la sociedad sin el afán de
discriminar lo juzgue lo que se debe
hacer es
ofrecerle a la persona que ejerce la
prostitución esquemas dignos de trabajo
otras opciones capacitaciones para el
trabajo otras opciones que en donde sus
derechos humanos puedan ser
salvaguardados porque nosotros pensamos
en nuestra organización y todas las
organizaciones que luchamos contra la
trata de personas que esta actividad
deja y
[Música]
humilla y este y destruye a la persona
las personas en estado de prostitución
pueden ser víctimas de contraer
enfermedades de ser violentadas
fuertemente hasta de morir en el
ejercicio de esta profesión entonces
nosotros creemos que los gobiernos y la
sociedad civil debemos comprometernos a
ofrecerles opciones donde sus derechos
no sean viole este violentados bueno y
más allá de eso de todos estos peligros
que yo diría son bastante obvios sin
necesidad de revisar muy a fondo pues
ahora tenemos otro problema y es este
enemigo invisible que es el virus kobe
19 entonces cuando una mujer está en
situación de prostitución no hay
distanciamiento social no hay
posibilidad de aplicar ninguna clase de
bioseguridad dentro de esta práctica así
que como proteger realmente a las
mujeres que están en prostitución
es que no no existe una forma tú tienes
toda la razón cómo se puede hacer
ejercer si se si una persona que ejerce
la prostitución tiene que darle gusto al
cliente cómo puede protegerse de no ser
contagiada o de no contagiar al mismo
cliente no aquí tenemos un foco de salud
en donde las autoridades tienen que
estar ahí alerta de este foco de salud y
este y cuidar los derechos de las
personas esté efectivamente bueno
nosotros tenemos cifras importantísimas
en donde solamente el 2 por ciento de
las personas que son salvadas de la
trata de personas en el ejercicio de la
explotación sexual sobreviven ya sin
hablar de comida entonces ellas por la
violencia por los traumas por por los
peligros que tiene su salud porque
pueden tener vih que los lleve a tener
cáncer
cáncer cervicouterino o porque la misma
violencia las puede llevar a la
depresión y el suicidio es muy bajo el
índice de supervivencia en el ejercicio
de la explotación sexual y a eso es
emiliano que ahora tienen que sobrevivir
también el hobby 19
voy a pedirle una última pregunta porque
ya se nos acaba el tiempo precisamente
ahora que mencioné el tema del control
de vih/sida un estudio del centro
nacional para la prevención de esta
enfermedad
habló de 78% de las mujeres que están en
prostitución que son madres que tienen
hijos entonces aquí los mecanismos de
ayuda no solamente son para un individuo
sino para todo un tejido social y para
la conformación familiares de estas
mujeres por favor para que usted nos
resalte pues la gravedad de esta
problemática bueno por ejemplo nosotras
tenemos víctimas que tienen el virus vih
y además son menores de edad es muy
difícil distinguir si por ejemplo se
hiciera el sexoservicio se asumiera como
una profesión digna como vamos a
controlar que las que las personas que
están enganchadas en el sexoservicio no
sean esclavas sexuales o sea no estén
controladas por organizaciones o por lo
que llamamos padrotes o traficantes y
este y cómo vamos a controlar va a tener
un control de enfermedades atender una
persona con vih con su hijo o hija que
también lo tienen porque lo adquieren
por la convivencia y la misma maternidad
pues es estar dejando ahí un espacio en
donde no podemos defender el derecho a
la salud entonces este es efectivamente
un problema muy grave de controlar y
este y si no podemos controlar
epidemias o enfermedades que ya tienen
décadas
tratándose de abordar ahora con el copy
19 todo este mal se potencializa y se
hace mucho más difícil
y desde la sociedad tenemos que ver esta
prevención pues dirían muchísimas
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros y
nos queda la pregunta esta cuestión que
siempre queda en el aire y ese que tanto
se ejerce por vocación o por gusto es
una tarea o una práctica que ciertamente
es un negocio rentable es uno de los más
rentables del mundo pero que también
trabaja dentro de un esquema de
esclavización gracias a ustedes por
estar con nosotros en france 24 y nos
vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]